[Music]
welcome back to language shapes
perception example you may find it
difficult to have a conversation about
poor employee performance or behavior
complaints and grievances giving bad
news such as ending employment or
advising unsuccessful job
applicants some conversations can be
tough to handle so whenever you find
yourself in those situations it can help
to use the fist
of
[Music]
what is the fist of five method it
allows you to check in with your
emotions and helps you decide what to do
next if you're ready to say something or
if you should wait a little longer to
calm yourself down before saying
anything or making any decisions you can
ask yourself how do I feel about this am
I comfortable to talk about about this
topic do I need to organize my thoughts
before proceeding before I say anything
and the last one what kind of
preparations do I need to do before I
start this
conversation so fist of five includes
fist you're not very at ease one finger
two fingers three fingers four fingers
and finally if you're very comfortable
and you feel prepared before starting
the conversation or uh continuing with
the voting or whatever the conversation
is about you hold out five fingers and
that means you're
ready use the fist to five method to
gauge your emotions before engaging in
any discussion especially if that's an
argument or a heated discussion the
first one fist when you hold your fist
that means that I'm not very at ease and
I don't want to proceed with this
conversation if you point out one finger
that means that I'm not at ease and I
need support before proceeding so I'm
not ready when you hold two fingers that
means that you feel a little uneasy but
you want to try and
proceed when you point out three fingers
that means that you're unsure how you
feel most probably you will start
talking and say
something when you hold out four fingers
that means that you're at ease enough to
proceed with the conversation whether
that's a voting or you're talking about
something really important for you the
last one is is if you hold five
fingers that means that you're very at
ease and you you feel very comfortable
to proceed with any
conversation or your thoughts are very
organized and you feel confident to talk
about
[Music]
anything